ADAM POWELL: Hi there.
So as Dave said, we're always
a little bit more personable
right after lunch.
We're also a little bit more
excitable right after coffee.
So you're catching
us at a good time.
YIGIT BOYAR: Yeah,
just had coffee.
ADAM POWELL: So this talk
is about Android application
architecture.
I'm Adam Powell.
I'm on the Android
framework team.
YIGIT BOYAR: I'm Yigit Boyar.
I'm also in the
Android framework team.
ADAM POWELL: So this
is actually going
to be a little bit of a
special extended edition
version of a talk that we gave
earlier this year at Google
I/O. And just like every
good special edition,
the original version
isn't available on video.
So here you are.
So the important thing about
application architecture
is, really, you need to act
early in your applications.
As soon as you
start writing code,
you've made these
decisions that are
going to affect how your
application is going to be
developed from there forward.
So those decisions
stick with you.
These really, really deeply
influence your application.
And we're going to show
you a few of the ways
that this really affects
how you might write
your app as you move forward.
It really makes it
easier or harder
to think about the problems
that you're really setting
to solve in your application.
So you might be asking, OK,
well, which patterns do I use?
There's a lot of
stuff out there.
And you can really get
into a lot of alphabet soup
as you start looking over all
of the different prescriptive
patterns that you
can look into--
YIGIT BOYAR: I'm super confused.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah, I mean,
I've got all these things here.
YIGIT BOYAR: That's
me, by the way.
That's me, this cartoon.
ADAM POWELL: So this isn't
a survey of libraries.
That's not what we're
here to talk about today.
There really are a lot of
great libraries out there.
And you should really
look into many of them
and see what they
can do for you.
And the trends change quickly.
The challenges you're going
to face are really timeless.
The properties of some of these
devices that we're writing for
have been the same properties
from the first time
any one of us held a smartphone.
And really, lava flow
happens over time.
This is kind of this
phenomenon where,
after your code goes through
a number of refactorings,
there isn't really kind of
an overarching principle
that ties it all
together anymore.
Someone new who comes
to your code base
may or may not
understand what's going
on as you start piling up
all of these different pieces
that really no
longer fit together.
The important takeaway
from this is to architect
for user experience.
Really, nobody in
your user base is
going to care exactly
what patterns you used
to produce your application.
They're going to care about
the experience that they have
while they've got
it in their hand.
YIGIT BOYAR: All right, so
let's look at some examples.
There's some videos.
So here's an application.
It's very simple.
I'm posting a comment on
a photo, trying to type.
All right, there you go, Send.
And I'm waiting.
Why am I waiting?
I have no idea.
I'm just waiting, waiting.
All right, it sent.
So what was the problem here?
So what's happening was, the
user clicks on the Send button.
It goes to your controller,
goes to your network,
network comes back whenever
it wants to come back.
And then you update your UI.
Meanwhile, you blocked
the user because you
don't know what happened.
Maybe the comment will not go.
What if we get rid of
this, introduce something
you can call a model, which
is your storage, which
is where you keep your
comments and everything?
So then when the user
hits the Send button,
you keep it in your
model, update your UI,
then tell the network
that this has been added.
And when the network comes
back, you can update your UI.
So let's look at the
same example, this time
with the fix, how it looks.
So I come here.
I type my comment--
the same comment
so you make sure it's
the same use case.
I send it.
I still see the comment.
It's a little bit gray,
but I see it there.
When the network finally
comes back, it turns black.
User has a clue.
You can design it better.
I couldn't.
But that's the idea.
You give the feedback instantly.
ADAM POWELL: Your
designers are wonderful.
Make sure that you
appreciate them.
YIGIT BOYAR: I told you, why
did you give me a design job?
OK, let's look at one more demo.
It's the same puppy.
So I keep commenting
that I really like it.
I keep commenting.
And I hit Send.
OK, you're going to see
that it's greyed out.
I see the responses only.
That's great.
It turns black.
I go back to that page again.
It's empty.
Like, I was here
literally two seconds ago.
I came back.
I come back to the page,
and it's not there.
This is inconsistent.
I feel like something got lost.
So what was happening here?
So the view controller, as we
said before, told the model,
model told the
network, it came back,
we updated the UI-- great.
But the problem is the
model didn't have anything.
It only is still
fed by the network.
What if, instead, you
kept a persistent model?
So the idea is that your
data stays on your client.
There's something
that you can always
access unless the phone crashes,
which-- you can't do anything
in that case.
Instead, we have some
application logic
that is responsible
to synchronize network
and your persistent model.
It's really important
to look at this problem
as a synchronization problem
rather than making API calls.
That simplifies a lot.
So this application logic
syncs with the network,
fetches whatever
you want to fetch,
updates the model, then just
notifies in the event-- OK,
I'm done.
I made some changes.
Hey guys, if anybody wants to
know about it, here they are.
And then your view
controller goes and fetches
the data and updates the view.
Let's say the user clicked
on the Send button.
The view control tells the
application logic, OK, I
have this comment.
Please send it.
The logic instantly
updates the disk.
That's the first
thing you have to do.
You update the local
storage and tell, hey,
I updated this comment.
I added this comment.
And it also calls the network.
Now, there's two things
going on right now.
While you're making
the network query,
the view controller
gets notified.
OK, I have a new comment
to fetch, goes to model,
update the UI.
When the network finally
returns, the application logic
updates the model
again and says, OK,
I seek to comment to server.
If anybody's inserted,
do something.
And then the view controller
goes, updates the view again.
So everybody has
very simple duties.
And they are decoupled.
So see how it looks when
we implement it properly.
I come here.
It's instant.
Because it's coming
from the local storage.
It cannot be slow unless
something is going really bad
on your device, which
sometimes happens.
All right, so one more
example-- OK, it's running.
So I'm so excited that
I keep sending comments.
But they're only seeing
the first comment I sent.
Something is-- oh, OK,
they just showed up.
ADAM POWELL: What
happened there?
YIGIT BOYAR: I don't know.
What happened there?
Now I figure out
what happened there.
So this was my background.
Because I had this great
pool on the background
that processes all
these things one by one
so that I don't create
too many threads.
So And I loaded the activity
to-- a fetch bitmap job
came for the photo, and the
other one to load the comments
from the disk.
So I had two executors.
They started running.
Meanwhile, this user started
spamming my application
with all these new comments.
I finished it in the comments.
The other one came.
We put the comment in the disk.
And now we are trying
to send it to servers.
Meanwhile, the
network is really bad.
So the fetch bitmap
job is still running.
The view controller
got the notification
about the new comment and
wanted to refresh itself.
But the queue already is full.
I'm using.
And then the job cannot run.
So the UI is not
updating because I'm
trying to fetch a bitmap.
This is bad.
That means the
priorities are not good.
But it's very hard to know.
You don't know how
long the job will take.
You cannot estimate
it all the time.
But what you can do is
separate these things.
So if I have a different
queue for my network tasks,
and a different queue
for my local tasks,
when my network is
flaky, my application
is still responsive.
Because they are never affected.
So if we're on
the same jobs that
were on the previous
center, as you can see now,
they're going into
different threads.
And the local test
queue just keeps
running because disk fine.
Because we couldn't fetch the
bitmap, we couldn't update.
We couldn't send the
comment to server.
But who cares-- user
is still seeing it.
And if we make the
changes, well, you
see everything is sending.
And as it gets time to
run the server jobs,
we're seeing there
they're starting to turn
black, from top, one by one.
They will eventually be synced.
So one of the feedbacks we
get after [INAUDIBLE] is, OK,
but how does the
activity get notified?
So activity is a very,
very simple state machine
in this scenario.
When it is created,
you set up your UI.
That's all you do.
When you start, you
register for the events
you want to know about.
And you load your data.
This is how it ensures
that between restarts
or whatever, if there
are some events you miss,
you'll never miss them.
Because the onStart,
you register
and you refresh your data.
And when an event comes,
just refresh your data.
It's like the same
thing over and over.
OnStop-- don't
refresh your data.
You just unregister from events.
So your life cycle
is very simple.
Like, this happens, I do this.
This happens, I do this.
This makes it easier to
test, much more stable, much
more easier to understand.
OK, back to you, Adam.
ADAM POWELL: All right, so the
key takeaway from all the demo
that we just saw
there was, really, you
need to design for offline.
Always assume that the
network is not your friend.
It's going to be slow.
And if you want to deliver
a good user experience,
you really can't just blame
the network for why something
isn't popping in quickly.
The table stakes
have really been
raised on this when
it comes to mobile.
So to solve this, back
your UI with a local model
and use your other
application logic
to sync the model and
server rather than doing
this as live API calls.
It can be really tempting to
try to optimize for the case
where you want data freshness
above all else, where you
really don't want to
show anything to the user
unless you're really,
really sure about it.
But this is one of
those things where,
if you assume success
versus assuming failure,
then what types of claims
are you really making
about your software
when you assume
failure in the common case?
I mean, your software
is going to work, right?
Your server is going to
come back with the answer
that you expected, right?
So optimize for those cases.
Predict it.
Show it to the user early.
YIGIT BOYAR: By the way,
I just learned yesterday
there's is a fancy new name
called optimistic rendering.
I feel like now it is
ADAM POWELL: Yeah,
you see this principle
at work in a lot of other
areas of software development
as well.
Games is one really
prominent example
where a lot of network
latency compensation
systems in multiplayer games
are based on this principle.
They predict based
on what happened
in the previous known
state from the network.
So you can use these same
ideas in your own apps.
So make sure that these
things don't necessarily
depend on each other unless
it's in a very loose fashion.
Use events and
callbacks and such
when needed to notify
other parts of your system
about a state that's changed.
So everybody always asks us
about dependency injection
as well.
Is it good?
Is it bad?
What should I use?
What library should I use?
Well, I mean, use
it if it helps.
Everything has a cost.
So know the side effects of
what it is that you're doing
and what it is that
you're including.
It's very, very easy to
include a new dependency
in your application.
And it's not always easy to
see what the costs of that
are going to be at run time,
especially when you're just
bench testing at your desk.
Everything is in the optimal
case when you're sitting there
at your desk.
So avoid reflection for
better performance as well.
Many dependency
injection frameworks
have a heavy runtime component
versus a compile time
component.
Some systems like Dagger
2 do this at compile time,
and it ends up being much more
optimal for your application.
So take a look into these and
see what the tradeoffs are.
When it comes to networking,
so we talked about other things
that we can do.
Always assume the network
is going to be slow, janky.
Always assume that
you've got your phone
in the middle of a conference
with a crowded Wi-Fi
and completely
slammed cell towers.
That's basically your case that
you want to optimize for here.
Because this is when people
are going to notice that
your application is
broken when it falls over.
So your API design
at the network layer
can actually affect
this as well.
So design your back end for
your client, not the other way
around.
And this is one of those things
that sounds really obvious when
you get up here and say it.
But as you start building server
back ends for these things,
you start exposing
pieces that you
may need, so on and so forth.
And really you start building
it up as a series of layers.
So you have the very
low level components
that provide your data,
such as the network.
And then you have the
higher level components
that provide the presentation.
And it's very tempting to not
have the higher levels inform
the design of the lower levels.
But you can get a lot
of wins by doing this.
Also, process as much
as you can on the server
side to begin with.
You have these
big, beefy servers
in the cloud that can do
a lot of work for you.
Don't offload stuff to the
client that you don't have to.
More specifically, pass
metadata to the client.
This is something that
can really, really improve
your user experience.
If you have a
large blob of data,
such as a big photo, that
you're going to pull down
as part of syncing some sort
of social app, for example,
what do you know about
this image at the time
that you've made this request
and gotten this response back?
Well, not a whole lot.
So what are you going to show
while that loads, while you
actually go fetch that image?
A better case would be to
pass along a little bit
more metadata.
Give your application some
hints that it needs to succeed.
In this case, we're passing
the width and height
of this image in advance before
we go fetch the image itself.
This allows us to perfectly
size a placeholder in our UI
so that you don't have your
UI jumping back and forth
as the user scrolls
through or attempts
to move back and forth.
We've also passed along
some palette information
here just to be able to give
our UI a little bit more
of a splash of color that
keeps the flavor of the image
before we actually
have the real bits.
Battery and data--
this is another concern
that you've got whenever
you're talking to the network
as well, especially
when you're doing
any sort of background syncing.
Batch your requests
as much as possible.
Now, we've provided
a lot of other tools
in recent versions of Android
to help you do this effectively.
Things like Doze and
Marshmallow are great examples.
Doze will do a lot
of this for you.
But really, don't just rely
on that as your sole way
of dealing with this.
Doze is essentially
the last line
of defense for the
user at this point.
Use the job scheduler
when it makes sense.
Give Android as much
information about what
it is that your app is
actually trying to do.
And that way, Android
can make smarter
decisions about how
best to optimize that.
The key takeaway here is
act locally, sync globally.
You really want to give the user
a very fast, very responsive
local experience whenever
they're using your application.
And then make sure that you
keep that in sync with the cloud
almost as an afterthought
compared with the presentation
that you're trying to give.
So no talk of
application architecture
would be complete
without some sort
of addressing of the question
of activities and fragments.
This is something that we
constantly get questions about,
even within Google.
We'll get questions, like, OK,
well, should I use activities
or should I use fragments
to build my app?
It's like, well,
that doesn't entirely
make a whole lot of
sense to question.
Fragments are really
just encapsulated parts
of an activity.
So when you build
up your application,
when your activity
starts getting too big,
and you need to
start breaking it up
so you can still think
about it effectively,
it's a great time to break
it down into some fragments.
Or if you start by building
single fragments that sort
of compose together a
little bit more than that
so that you keep your
concerns separated,
that can help keep
things a little bit more
straight in your
head so that you
don't end up with these
giant activity god classes.
Fragments and views is
another one that we get a lot.
Now, this is
something that we talk
about quite a bit on
the framework team
in terms of, one of
the almost regrets
of the fragment
API at this point
is that you've got this handy
little tag that you can just
stick in your layout that
says, fragment, and says,
go ahead and
instantiate a fragment
and stick it right here in
my layout when I inflate it.
And this thing is really,
really convenient.
It makes for great code
examples and demos,
because you can do things
like have a layout that sticks
two fragments side by side.
And then you rotate the
device, and it sticks them
stacked on top of one another.
And you say, hey, look.
Look at this great decoupled
system that I've got.
It makes for fantastic demo.
But realistically,
this makes people
think of fragments as being
view constructs themselves.
And really, they kind of aren't.
So they live in these
very different worlds.
So views are really the
nuts and bolts of your UIs
that you're building, whereas
activities and fragments are
the lifecycle constructs
that basically provide
the plug-in points of contact
with the rest of the system
that tells you what's going on.
So many times,
you're going to want
to use both to keep these
responsibilities clear.
Just as Yigit mentioned
earlier, you're
going to want to use
these signals that you
get from your activity and,
in conjunction with that,
through your fragments as
well, if you're using those,
to basically inform when you
should register, unregister
for events, so on and so forth.
But the views should really be
their own encapsulated pieces
separate from that
that are controlled
by these other constructs.
OK, so moving along to another
topic of contention often--
memory.
So this is something
that we talk about a lot.
If you've watched
any of Colt's talks
on the Android
performance practices,
you've seen some of these.
Avoid allocating objects
in hot code paths.
Putting pressure on
the GC is not so great.
Art is a lot better
at this these days
than Android used to
be at all of this.
But there's still a lot of
those devices out in the wild.
And if you watch this in a
few sensitive code paths,
then you're going to
end up with a little bit
of a smoother experience.
So you can pool and
reuse some objects
when you measure a problem.
That last part is
really the key--
when you measure a problem.
Make sure that you're measuring
these things before you go
and contort the
internals of your system.
And these are the sorts of
things where, some things, you
can make some decisions
early that will
help you move into
these optimizations
should you need them.
And some things, it
really doesn't matter.
So write the code the way
that it's clearer first
and then optimize later.
So GC still kind of
remains your enemy,
especially on some of
these older devices,
even as the garbage collector
in Android gets much better.
So a perfect example of how
this may affect your API design
internally-- just with
smaller components.
Now, what's the difference
between these two approaches?
Well, the top one is arguably
more idiomatic, much cleaner.
You can make some assumptions
about it in terms of, OK, well,
the object it returns
is hopefully safe
if that's a mutable
object to begin with.
But in order for
that to be true, then
this getter has to be
allocating a new rect for me
that it returns.
Well, now we've got allocation.
So where do you
end up using that?
Versus the second form here,
which is basically just taking
an input parameter that the
method is going to fill out.
You know that the
second one isn't
going to perform any additional
allocation in this case.
This is the sort of
thing that you really
only want to worry about in
extremely hot code paths.
We're talking layout that
gets run many, many times.
We're talking drawing that
gets run 60 times per second.
If you're talking
about things that
happen in terms of
your event handlers,
like clicks, and so
on, and so forth,
you really don't need to
be contorting your system
this much internally.
But for that very small
percentage of your code,
it is OK to write ugly code
if it helps your users.
Your users are not
going to see your code.
They're going to see your UI.
If your UI is ugly because
it's behaving badly,
then that's something
that they do see.
That's something that really
does affect their experience.
The performance critical code
really isn't the majority.
And, well, all compiled code
looks ugly eventually anyways.
So with that, we're
going to move over
to another demo that kind of
brings a bunch of these ideas
together.
YIGIT BOYAR: OK, so
after the I/O talk,
one of the feedbacks we received
was, OK, talk these things,
but show me some code.
So this time, we wrote
this sample application.
Keep in mind, this is
a sample implication.
And the main focus
here is, how do you
look at this problem more as
a synchronization problem?
How do you design an
application to work offline?
And we are going to
release the source code.
I'm just waiting
for some approvals.
So here's my application.
I just lost my Chrome.
All right.
Let's come here.
So it's a real app.
There is a real server
running on my computer
just for the
purpose of the demo.
And the application is
just a list of posts.
Hello, everybody, I can say.
I can say, everybody.
So how does this work?
So let's do something dangerous.
And it's not that dangerous.
I'll do more dangerous
things later.
So I just disabled the network.
And I send one more.
So right now, please
forgive my UI.
So there is an upload club
on the right bottom of text
that tells the user, this is
not the same as other ones.
It's almost going to send.
It's not there yet,
so if I actually
look at my real server.
And my application, when
the network recovers,
it will eventually post it.
And it's going to update the UI.
Now, with some other examples
we saw in the previous time--
actually, we can
crash the server, too.
So now the server is
not running anymore.
So for this demo, I have a
very simple back off time.
But it'll try back off.
ADAM POWELL: I mean,
it does cry, too.
YIGIT BOYAR: These are
my application-- yeah,
it does cry too.
These are my
application logs here.
It actually keeps trying to post
it, because there is network.
It's just the
server is crashing.
And now I finally bring
the server up-- oops,
not like that, not like that.
OK, so it started backing off.
It will eventually send
the comment to the server.
It Dies there.
It keeps retrying.
And yes, it did send.
So let's do one more case where
we do crash the server again.
OK, one more comment--
it's the same.
Oh wait, it didn't crash.
Sorry, I crashed the logger.
So we crashed the
server this time.
See, the application works.
ADAM POWELL: You wrote a server
that doesn't even crash right.
Come on, what do we have here?
YIGIT BOYAR: It should crash
for the purpose of the demo.
I hope your servers won't crash.
So I sent one more comment.
And then I simply go out.
So my emulator
may crash, though.
It's been having some problems.
I did go out.
And I am going to
kill that application.
I come back.
OK, so the comment
is still there.
It cannot update the feed, but
the comment is waiting for me
there.
And I will just run the server.
The screen does
eventually synchronise.
So the idea is the
application doesn't care
about when the comment goes.
It's staying in the disk
waiting to be uploaded.
There is some other job that's
taking care of the upload.
But it will eventually
go to server,
unless I have a bug, of course.
So how do we take
care of these things?
The way it works is we
have this feed activity.
By the way, again, this
is a demo application.
I'm trying to focus
on certain things.
There might be toerh problems
with this demo application.
The important take away is the
thing we're focusing on here.
So this application,
when you call Send Post,
it simply tells the feed
controller to send the post.
Which, as the job to
the disk-- there's
something persistent
that will eventually run,
which is responsible
to update the disk,
as well as sending the post.
So it updates the disk.
And then this
[? pitches ?] an event.
When this event is
this page, my activity
knows about this event,
refreshes itself.
When it runs, it
does the same thing.
Or when it's cancelled,
it does the same thing.
This is a persistent job.
That means it's going
to be saved in the disk
until it succeeds or
reaches the retry limit.
They say, OK, all right.
The comment is posted-- nice.
And so another problem
about synchronization--
what happens if I'm offline?
Send comments.
So it's not working, eventually.
And I go to this website.
And I create a comment here.
I'm from the web.
So now these two states
are inconsistent.
My client doesn't know
about the new one.
And I have a comment locally.
So if I enable my
network-- by the way,
normally, when the
network comes back,
you would refresh your feed.
But I'm not doing it for
the purpose of the demo.
So when the network
comes back, it's
going to send the
post instantly.
So it's out of sync.
But when I eventually
refresh, it's
going to add anyone
to the correct order.
This is because everything is
time stamped by the server.
So until a post is
sent to the server,
you make a best guess
time stamp on it.
So for this example, the
way I do it is-- again,
it may change per
your application.
But the way this
one does is-- wait,
let me open the [? safe ?].
OK, so when it
creates, it actually
creates the model to get
the best time stamp I have.
This is a way to synchronize
if my client's time is, really,
really off.
And if the new comment is not on
top, that may look really bad.
Because it changed your server
ordering, your UI ordering.
But that may cause problems.
So what I do here is I assign
a best case time stamp locally.
And then we do it
on later on server.
So we get the network again.
And again, like another case,
because of the persistence,
so I send the post here,
click on the usernames,
moves it to the user's post.
And it's done.
I never fetched this user feed.
But the post is there.
It's everywhere
in my application.
Because it's on my disk.
I don't care if it
is not synced or not.
I have a proper model
for that object.
It's a simple value object.
But it's always working.
And let's say, I'm
in the user feed,
but then recover the network.
It will eventually send.
And the feed will update, too.
If I go back, it's already
updated here instantly.
This is because if a UI is
interested in a certain event,
it listens for it.
Now, I'm using a
global event bus here.
You can probably
implement the same thing
with RX or Broadcase.
This is a sample application
that does it this way,
and it works.
There might be
multiple ways to do
the same thing, the right
thing, or maybe a better way.
So we'll get more fancy.
OK, what if the
server is crashing?
So this is my real
server, by the way.
It's a lot of fun.
It's a magical language.
So I'm going to
turn on a flag here.
What this will do is the server
is going to save the post,
but it's going to
crash afterwards.
So I won't be able
to realize that I
could synchronize that post.
So the server is crashing now.
I go back here.
I can say, OK, [INAUDIBLE].
So the job tries 20 times.
And it backs off 250
milliseconds exponentially.
So if will keep trying,
trying, trying, try me again.
So now the server is crashing,
as you can see the crash logs.
It saved the post to the disk.
But the client doesn't know.
So the client keeps retrying.
But what happens is
that your fetch feeds
post endpoint is working fine.
So you refresh.
So the post came back.
I know it's the same post.
So how do I know
it's the same post?
This comes into a
little bit API design.
But we want to do a full demo.
So I did figure out it's the
same post and updated it.
Although my sent posts
have never succeeded.
So the way it works
in this application
is, by design, each element
is assigned a client ID.
So if you look at these examples
here-- are they visible?
Yeah, all right, so
there's a user ID.
And there's also a client ID.
This client ID is
randomly generated
a unique per user per post.
So there is a unique
key in my [INAUDIBLE].
It says user ID and client ID.
It's a unique tuple.
You rely on the fact that
it's not going to conflict.
I mean, technically it can.
Probably it won't.
So by doing this, when I receive
the post from the server,
I know the post already
exists in my disk.
And I update that one, saying
that, OK, I sync this one.
I don't know what
happened to the job.
I don't care.
And then the job
knows while running.
Before trying to send
the post, it checks, hey,
is this already synced?
So here, if you can see the
code here, it just loads it.
And if it's already
synchronized,
it doesn't do anything.
Oh, hey, this has been updated.
Good news.
Everything is working fine.
So one more thing--
OK, so the last idea
here is that this works because
we look at the problem as two
separate problems.
One of them is
only responsible--
take the user interaction,
process the model locally.
And the other one is responsible
to synchronize with the server
however it does.
It's not trivial.
You're writing a bunch of
additional code to say,
local client IDs have
to handle conflicts.
But it works.
So let's look at
one more demo here.
This time, I will
shut down the server.
So I'm sending-- I'm
again that excited kid.
I keep sending all
these messages.
Of course, they're
not going to go.
If I look at here,
they're not going.
When I recover the server, now
the first job is backing off.
It will eventually finish.
Meanwhile, I can send more.
As you can see, they are going
out one by one, one by one,
in the correct order--
my scroll position lost.
This works because
these jobs are
running through the
same queue per pause.
So I know that whoever came
first will be handled first.
So we guarantee that
they are in order.
We cannot guarantee
they are time stamped.
Because that's
technically not possible
unless you want to rely on
what your client timestamp is.
But we granted their order.
Again, this is all
independent of the UI.
It doesn't care at all.
The only thing it knows is, how
do I load this from the disk,
and how do I send these comments
to my application logic?
One more example I
want to go-- actually I
want to go through this code.
So one of the problems with
this event-driven architecture
is since all these
events are happening,
how do I synchronize?
What if I miss an event?
Or what if the timeline's
timestamps don't match?
Again, for this
demo application,
the way this one works is every
single event that is important
comes with a timestamp.
So for example, for
fetching a feed event,
timestamp is the timestamp
of the oldest post.
So if someone is going
to load those once,
it makes sure it includes
that timestamp in the query.
So it loads things
afterwards, that.
So every time the feed
activity receives an event--
let's say [INAUDIBLE]-- it
checks if this is for my user.
And if this is for
my user, it just
calls the refresh
with the oldest one.
And then that refresh method,
while querying the model,
it uses that timestamp.
Or if there's no
timestamp, it uses top one.
Because you don't want to
keep refreshing things.
Yeah, that is, mostly-- let
me see if I miss anything.
OK, I think we are going
to publish this code, both
the server side and
the client side,
to Github as soon as-- I
needed some clarification here
and there.
But you can play with it.
We'll be happy to
get [INAUDIBLE]
or whatever if you think
something could be done better.
And it's nice to share and
just move on from there.
All right, sure, that's it.
It's time for some questions.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM POWELL: I think that
we've got a microphone floating
around perhaps.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: Will it contain tests?
YIGIT BOYAR: Huh?
AUDIENCE: Will the
project contain tests?
YIGIT BOYAR: Yes,
it actually does.
So actually, I should
have showed it.
So if you look at-- well,
they may not be great tests.
I am not a testing expert.
But they do test.
They're mostly
interrogation tests.
If you look at something more
fancy, for example, fetching
the feed, so I say we do--
ADAM POWELL: Can we
switch the slide back over
to the computer real quick?
YIGIT BOYAR: Oh, sorry.
Can we go back to the computer?
OK, thank you.
So the application uses Dagger.
This is how I marked
some of the API calls.
But let's see-- fetch
feed, no, send comment.
That will be nice.
ADAM POWELL: So
short answer, yes.
YIGIT BOYAR: They are here.
I had some very nice tests.
I cannot find-- OK, I found it.
400.
So this is creating the
job, mocking the API service
so that if someone tries
to send a post, return 404.
That injects the test
component, runs the job,
checks the appropriate
event to send.
So one of the things is when
some outputs happen as events,
it's not very easy to test them.
In this example I'm using,
in the test application,
I'm using a logging
event bus that basically
logs every single event so that
I can assert on those later on.
Again, there might be different
or better ways to do this.
But this is
something that works.
And we have tests.
AUDIENCE: What's your opinion
on using custom views instead
of fragments so you don't
have to deal with the fragment
quirks, if you will?
So things like child fragment
manager or popping in the back
stack after you
have a saved state.
ADAM POWELL: So again,
I think that those
are kind of unrelated.
Just because a fragment
controls views.
It's not a view itself.
That was kind of
what we were trying
to get at a little bit earlier.
Overall, I think
that a lot of people
write fragments when they really
meant to write a custom view.
So I think that in many
cases, see exactly what it
is that your particular
chunk of encapsulated UI
needs to express and respond to.
If those are events
that can be coming
from some alternate
component that's
kind of composing that piece's
place within the overall UI,
then that speaks to it being
probably a little bit more
like a view group.
If it's something
that really needs
to respond to other
elements of the application
lifecycle and the
activity lifecycle,
if it's doing something
like registering for events,
dealing with things
like that, then it
may be more appropriate for
a fragment in that case.
But overall, I think
that people tend
to lean a little bit
too heavily on fragments
when they think of one
particular subsegment
of their UI.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
One question I had
was, how do you
handle the serialization
of these jobs to disk
and back out when the app dies?
Do you roll your own logic,
or do you use something
like a framework or something?
YIGIT BOYAR: For this
demo application,
I'm using Job Queue, which is
some library I wrote before.
You can simply serialize them.
You can use Tape.
There was recently
another talk to use
Tape to serialize your
stuff, to make it like a job.
There's multiple solutions
for this out there.
It's not that complex either.
You can choose one of them
which fits your needs.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
ADAM POWELL: We've
got one up front.
AUDIENCE: In this
kind of application,
would you use a sync adapter,
or would you use like async REST
calls to contact the server?
YIGIT BOYAR: So
for the demo-- so
one of the things we gave
in examples in the slides
was to separate your local
tasks from the server tasks.
The way we do it is
for UI-related stuff,
I'm using a sync task.
I never use it for
network, only for UI stuff.
ANd for network, I'm
using the job queue.
So the jobs are the only ones
that are calling the network.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah, the sync
adapter is generally useful
once you have a more
sophisticated account
infrastructure, and you have
some of the other machinery
that that was really
kind of built around.
So if it seems like
you're going through a lot
of additional machinery to
work with a sync adapter,
then maybe start taking a
look at some more things,
just like a job scheduler,
and so on, and so forth,
and see if that's
something that is simpler
that can still meet your needs.
AUDIENCE: When you start
building all these applications
with these different
versions of data models--
so you might have, like, fetch
data off the network, updates
that the user has made to the
data that hasn't been actually
pushed to the database, do
you guys have any classes that
can help us maintain
all this application
logic or any libraries that
you would suggest we use
to maintain all these versions?
ADAM POWELL: Do you
have any suggestions?
YIGIT BOYAR: I'm sorry,
nothing about versioning.
But that actually reminds
me of something I forgot.
One of the important
things in your client
is your client's consistency.
And the server may crash.
But your server may also
start returning bad data.
So one of the things
this client does
is, if I open a user model,
let's say-- everything save.
So before we save
anything, we will date it.
And if it is not valid for this
client, we just throw it out.
Because I don't understand.
The server has a bug.
Maybe the server
is a new version.
I don't know.
If I don't understand
object, I throw it out.
This makes it easier for the
rest of the application to,
like, OK, if the object is
there, it's properly filled.
ADAM POWELL: So to the point
of dealing with specific data
inconsistencies,
especially across upgrades,
different server versions,
and so on and so forth,
what we found with working
with a lot of teams,
both within Google and
external to Google,
is that many times, the actual
pieces of business logic
that make an app
interesting tend
to differ so much between
applications that we've
had a lot of difficulty finding
a one size fits all solution
to just offer as a
prescription of, hey everyone,
go use this for dealing with
this particular problem space.
It is something that you can
make a lot of assumptions
based on the shape
of your data and what
it is that your data is
actually representing.
So often times, you need
something a lot less complex
than some general solution that
solves for the entire world.
But if you've got some ideas,
please track some of us
down in the halls here.
And we'd love to
hear about them.
Anyone else?
All right, well,
thank you very much.
YIGIT BOYAR: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]